it yeah okay we're back up that's so
obnoxious
it like Cuts up my stream and like just
like boots everybody off of
it it's really obnoxious
welcome
back don't know I don't know what's
wrong with this
thing I think I'm dropping xinity
they're like they're charging me for a
gig and giving me 100 megab uh
we have a set of
points we want to build it such that
every leite
node contains exactly one
point which is not always possible
yeah so here's your node which is 2 by
two
all the nodes is a single
array and use array indices as nodes
okay that's kind of
cool that's giv me some ideas this is
kind of like a heap right
faster
deletion
mhm you need to be able to look up
the indices though don't
you we need to be a look up the indices
was the hard
thing wait do I even need a recursive
tree there's absolutely no reason I need
a recursive tree
right am I just being dumb
wait I really just need this find like
this partition tree don't I like I need
the coarsest partition
if I just have a list of all of the uh
the agents in a chunk essentially if I
just use a chunk system instead of a
recursive
system and then I just check current
chunk and adjacent chunks
right I think that solves The Entity
loading
problem that does solve The Entity
the only thing I need to figure out is
essentially like the
vector you need something like the C++
Vector don't
you which can
be what's the uh what's the data
structure for a C++ vector
dynamically resizing
array list is a doubly linked
list and the set is
a that's actually really weird that a
set is a red black tree that's funny
um this is what I want is I want a list
I wanted just a doubly link list
I really don't want to have to use the
C++
linked but yeah you need you need some
data structure that you
can actually a doubly linked list is not
great is
it see the problem with wait does this
work okay I can see in my head how this
works
algorithmically but from just an
implementation perspective this is
pretty
tricky Welcome Back YouTube folks we're
online
um you know what since I've just kind of
been sitting here thinking out loud for
a bunch I'm going to diagram all this
cuz there's kind of a cool algorithmic
thing that you can do here I'm sure this
has been done in other games and
stuff but like this
is I mean it's an interesting and very
very performance sensitive thing so let
me let me draw this out for you
guys I wish there were a link I could
just paste in chat for this this would
would be funny okay anyways so you have
your game board right I'm going to draw
this over
here now right
now the way that I do this game
board um I just divide it up into tiles
so I mean this thing is this thing is
tile you can just pretend each of these
little uh gray or white cells as a
tile and it's pretty darn expensive to
do nearest uh neighbor checks not
nearest neighbor checks it's pretty darn
expensive to compute like all of the
agents within a 5x5 around you because
you have to look through all the
individual
tiles so what I could do is I could
partition this up into chunks
like this and then let's say that you're
right here somewhere your agent is
here then